pedro castillo lleva al congreso una de
sus promesas de campaña redactar una
nueva constitución en la fecha hemos
presentado al congreso de la república
un proyecto de reforma de la
constitución con la finalidad de que se
convoque a una asamblea constituyente
para que redacte un nuevo texto
constitucional después de haber
anunciado su iniciativa la semana pasada
el mandatario la presentó al parlamento
este lunes esta busca modificar el
artículo 206 de la constitución para
poder convocar a una asamblea
constituyente y contempla un referendo
en donde los ciudadanos podrán decidir
si están de acuerdo o no con crear una
nueva constitución
pero el proyecto ya tiene sus
detractores que la tildan de
inconstitucional primero porque el
presidente quiere incluirla en las
elecciones locales y segundo porque el
referendo debería ser invocado por la
ciudadanía este es un tema que no está
en la constitución
y
pero para que la iniciativa pueda ser
aceptada necesita la aprobación previa
del congreso por mayoría absoluta un
escenario difícil para el presidente que
se enfrenta a un parlamento dominado por
la oposición y que ya ha intentado
destituir a pedro castillo en dos
ocasiones en los nueve meses que lleva
en el gobierno
sin embargo el mandatario defiende el
referendo como la voluntad del pueblo y
como un paso para dejar en el pasado la
anterior acta magna promulgada en el
gobierno del ultraderechista alberto
fujimori todo parece indicar que la
mayoría de los peruanos no quieren una
nueva constitución sólo el 8% de la
ciudadanía la respalda según una
encuesta realizada por el instituto de
estudios peruanos